In this video, we'll begin to explore the Unreal Engine sample project that has been
created for this course.
When you extract the zip file that comes with this course, you'll see two different
folders, a packaged folder, which we'll review in the next video, and the UProject
folder.
Go ahead and open up the UProject folder, and in here you will see the Unreal Engine
project, osc53, which of course is designed for Unreal Engine 5.3, but should work
in newer versions of Unreal Engine as well.
So we'll go ahead and double click on that project.
Note the nice splash screen for our training.
And when the project opens, you should find yourself in the osc underscore example map,
where you'll see the third person example map, but with some additional numbered blue
cubes.
As Alex mentioned, this is a modified third person template.
Before we dive into all the blueprints here, let's just hit play and see what we have
here.
So once we hit play, we see we are in the normal third person template with some additional
cubes and a pink bar here.
So if we use right click to change the camera, we will see that the pink bar is
now on top of our head.
We're going to use this pink bar to show how to send location information to our OSC
client.
And if we hit Z on the keyboard, we will have this little window on the bottom left
corner.
We can use this type in text box to change the scale of the cube.
We can use this arrow key to change the color of the cube.
And we can use this button to show or hide the cube.
So we're actually using this widget to send a float value, change an integer value,
and send a boolean value from here.
Let's look into the OSC blueprint and where they are.
So all the cubes, the pink bar, the UI, and the OSC server and receiver are all
under content, OSC folder.
We'll be able to find everything here.
And let's briefly look into sender and receiver.
So on the sender side, these are all the nodes we have.
We have event to send integers, send bool, and send float.
And at the beginning play, we're going to specify if this app is a sender or not.
If it is a sender, it will go ahead and create OSC client.
If we want to do it two way, we will continue to add more logic,
which we will walk into detail in the later part.
And now let's move on to receiver from here.
Open the receiver side.
Similar to the sender, we will start with deciding if this is a receiver or not.
If it is a receiver, we'll go ahead and create an OSC server for it.
We use bind event to when there's an OSC message being received.
And we will do different things, depends on the OSC address.
In the next video, we'll utilize the packaged build
to demonstrate some additional functionality.